In this section, we're going
to take our sample
application that gives gifts
to our friends, and also
shows the gifts that we've
given them to show the gifts
that other friends
have given to us.
The first thing we need to do
is make a small change to
our gadget XML, so that we
have a place to insert our
list of received gifts.
Next we need to make two
small changes,
one to "loadFriends,"
and one to the "giveGift"
function, so that we have a
request for our friends' data,
as well as our own.
First, we modify "loadFriends,"
so that in addition to
requesting information on the
"viewer" and the "viewerFriends,"
as well as the viewer's
personal application data,
we also need to request the
"viewerFriends'" application data.
Next, we make the same change
in "giveGift" so that the
requests parallel each other.
Third, we update "onLoadFriends,"
so that in addition to pulling
out information on the "viewer,"
the "viewerFriends,"
and the "giftData,"
we pull out information on
"viewerfriendData,"
which is the list of gifts
that all of our
friends have given.
This function then iterates
through the list of friends,
displays the menus so that
you may select a friend
to give a gift to,
updates the gift list which shows
the list of gifts that you have sent,
finally, calls the new function
"updateReceivedList," which
shows the list of gifts that you
have received from your friends.
"updateReceivedList" closely
parallels "updateGiftList,"
but instead of iterating just
once through the list of gifts
that you have sent, it iterates
through each of your friends,
pulls out the application data
just for that friend specified
by your friend's Id, then
converts the data that it
pulls out into a
javascript object.
Once it has this list of gifts
that your friend have given,
it iterates through each of them,
comparing the friend Id that
the gift was sent to with your Id.
If the Ids match, it adds that
gift as a gift that was given to you.
Once the list of gifts
that have been given
to you has been completed,
they are inserted into the page.
Here you can see the newly
created version of our gadget,
that displays not just options
for sending gifts to our friends,
and the lists the gifts that we
have already sent to our friends,
but the list of gifts that
our friends have sent to us.
For more information on
what I just showed you,
as well as information
on the OpenSocial API,
check out the tutorial on
code.google.com
under the OpenSocial section.